nore
nano
dee
ano ん
オーボエ風上がれヘアー
tan tan アゾン
ni
na na na na na na na
ああああああ
me my car he can you do
can you do
uno だった
pou dou dou
ran これね
tarepa rs n
susana
me
こちら56 paranino
na na na
ane
me
ni
こちら000
ani came
anoano デー
5や編集の管理人がリーダーじゃない
9の仮縫いん
pou dou dou
me
far can
n ame
car
こちらへどうぞ planbe
aname
てるん
はいありがとうございます改めましてヨーヨーパフォーマンえっとオープニングね魔法
もせてきましたよパフォーマーの宝と言いますどうぞよろしくお願い致します
今日はてる x 和歌山 university にご覧いただき本当にありがとう
ございます
セレックスって名前なんで僕も少しだけスピーチをさせていただきたいと思います
動かす匹する内容はどうしてこうやってよパフォーマーになったか人前に立って療養
するようになったかそういうことです
here 直結するポジションなんで変化入ればぶーぶー言う
here 来て here こうやって情熱 pash
今日も欠けているものをこの人は馬鹿に出来るんだろうとかなんでこんなに熱中できる
ものをこの人は知らないんだろうとそういう気持ちになりました
それが僕の様パフォーマーとしての原点であります厳然というかエンジンというかそれ
のおかげでやろうと思った
そういう危険になりますそして中学校3年生の夏
中学校のサッカー部のですね引退がありましてインターンしてから必然のように僕は様
用地にとって練習するようになりましたそして中学校その3年生の冬ぐらいにですね
初めて舞台
ただしれることができましたその時はもう鮮明に覚えてるんですけども一つも技が
うまくいきませんでした
全部失敗してインターがた方に震え今僕これくらい大きいんですけどその後は160
センチぐらいだったんで何かそれよりちっちゃ感じました120センチぐらいしかない
かな
すごく自分が小さく感じました
その後も僕はいろんな努力をしたんですけれどもなんとうまくいきませんでした
ヨーヨーをどれだけ練習しても何かうまくなった気になれないし
またステージを正してもらったとしてもなんか違うなるって何かうまくいってる気がし
ないなそんな気になりました
今こうやって聴いてる音楽みたいにヒップホップこんなどんどんどんどんよような
こんな大きな t シャツ着たりとかお分かりやすい格好して
一方口の中でやってたんですけどもピポって遊華茶をもう一度勉強しなおしましたそれ
は最も
とストリートダンスであったりやっぱ楽にラップって言うなんていうんですかね
歌い方メロディーじゃなくて自分が頭の中にあるワードセンスだけで文字を並べて言っ
て歌を作る
まあストリートダンスだと街中でをとっている後のままステージに上がってその金を
ゲットするロスですねまぁ奴がどんどんどんどんキャブたに立っていっ
photo 場でお金をゲットする僕はそれよりヨーヨーつながるとそう信じてました
だってヨーヨーって皆さんどうでしょうかおもちゃ屋さんで見る時期と見ない時期って
あると思いませんか
結構流行りがあってこの時は流行ってるこの時は速くないこれが明確に分かれる思っ
ちゃう
それで僕はこれをもう1回僕が多いをもって日本区の音楽を流してこれを言う大きな
舞台に持って行くことをこれこそ hiphop なんじゃないから
僕の好きなヒップホップというカルチャー子なんじゃないかな療養というカルチャーに
とってもそれは大きなことじゃないから僕はそう防衛なりました
そう思ってから僕がよやることは全て変わりましたこうやって難しい技を真ん中で1
コマコマやるよりも今やったみたいに舞台の他市から端まで走り回ってみたりとかあと
はこんな
手のひらサイズなんで小さくて見えないなら僕がもっと大きく多くは最も長さを長く
するなんて具体的な方法もしました
いろんなことを重ねた結果高校2年生の冬
えっ zepp 名古屋という大きな会場の舞台にさせていただきました
1300人を超えるお客様の前でヨーヨーパフォーマンスをして先ほどみたいにこう
やって米をした瞬間僕は行ったと思いました
ここまできたと思いましたやっとつかんだと思います中学校2年生の頃
侮辱されたあの経験がここまできたと思いますが僕はこれが1本目送信白いなり
ましたん
here かにょ何事にも興味示さないみたいな風潮がって
僕もディスられていました
ようやっててもらう入りませんよねはいこむちゃねぇあの時は夏祭りのはもう
バシャバシャバシャ言われ水ヨーヨーって言うんですけど
あと間違うとこともありましたちゃうかなんてっ
僕がはの夜店のおっちゃんみたいにあれを持ってきてやると思ってたこともありました
そんなことがあったんですがその舞台で僕は揚々というものを勝ち取った気がしました
リポップという食べちゃうぞ使ってヨーヨーができるそうにそのスバイスを僕は知り
ましたそこで言ってしまえば終わりでよかったんでそこで止めればよかったんです
もう高校3年生ですからそれ進学なのか就職なのか選ばなきゃいけないしもっとやら
なきゃいけないこといやロス
がどうしてここに来たっているかこれはもう簡単なことです僕は記録が嫌いですね
コードです
1位23位とか100.910.4絶対あれが大嫌いです
僕はこうやってやることに記憶ですメモリ
こうやってお客さんの一人と実に見ていただいていてお客様の頭の中にちょっとでも
ヨーヨーでも
一方区でも療養パフォーマー僕自身の考えませんこれを植え付けられないかとそう
考えるになりました
それを考えたらそんな zepp 名古屋ぐらいの舞台で終われないと思いました
おっとやらなきゃっもっといろんなティアまで出ないといいがヌーやって1300人へ
非なんですけどやっぱり入ってきてみると何も変わってないんですねえんじゃ
ブーブことによって1人でも多くの人に両々ぴょいいくってそんな減ってるのは僕は
どこ行ってもにょ遊びに行ってもみんなが
82おったら7人が細い何か僕はこんな感じです
で僕は学校でもそんなに友達は多くありません
まあ明らかにヤンキーというよりかファンキーとかこうやってクレイジーてをれること
もありましたがそんな中でも僕はこのヒップホップというカルチャー
これが一番かっこいいそう信じています僕こそがヒップホップな相違張れるように僕は
これらからも頑張っていこうと思いますこれが僕のてレックスは買いも入りバーシーで
話が話したかった
スピリーしたかったことになりますこれから僕を含め順位のスピーカーさんがいます
それぞれのそれぞれのカルチャーそれぞれの観点からのものがあると思いますみなさん
の頭の中に10個メモリーが刻まれることを僕は切に願っています
今日は1日皆さんどうぞ楽しんでいってくださいありがとうございました
goo
dee
tee